ich nehme dir alles weg die schlüssel zu
dem hause liebig steht du liebst de
mercedes den gewürz ich nimm dir alles
weg und goethe dein bruder ja du hast
recht das leben ist nicht wer du bist
ein richtiger richtiger member der
generation kann akne
jo leute und herzlich willkommen tsum
fettesten gesangswettbewerb seit dsds
und mittlerweise tirol rechts von mir
der deine fördern 3 ohne seine jüngsten
und der andere musste ist zudem biete
und ich bin eine frische kräfte grafing
table wieder hier standardmäßig da
spiele ich bin am besten wieder starten
ich bin am bau steger ich bin locker ich
bei mir
und ja in dieser runde werden wir
herausfinden wer von uns am besten
singen kann und ich weiß mit meinst ich
kann das video vor spielen was ich
letztens was ich euch geschickt habe in
what's up bis zu 30 sekunden darfst du
ich hab nämlich einfach ich habe german
let's play hier gefunden mit samt kanal
germans träsch dasing der karaoke drauf
und ich muss sagen
probst an dich kann und ob dieses video
ist wahrscheinlich nicht aber wirklich
wirklich geil ich habe das richtig wie
er meine heart will go on singt einfach
geil es richtig jetzt ihr hier
ja
dass das bin ich im feature mit dem
video gelungen mich an du bist
sticker der welt im boden ich will
diesen fucking dingsda booms der diesen
blöden blog da aber auch leise sein dann
ja okay ich werde
denn ist der sitz in seiner kleinen
[ __ ] ist ein sohn ist heute die
musik einfach ohne musik nicht aus dem
kopf
gerade wenn ich richtig getötet ich
laufe behindert
sorry dafür versuchen gerade zu singen
wenn wir verlieren
stimmt es wirklich dass müssen offen
doch liegt ja ich bin
jubel in mina
ich glaub ich was in dem buch die liebe
ist einfach viel zu viel experte
ich nehme die jungs mit nicht schlüssel
zu dem haus lieblingsvideo liebsten
mercedes den du fährst ich nimm dir
alles weg und halte dein bruder ja du
hast recht das leben ist nicht wer
elektroschocker direkt in die kraft zum
papa was ist los man das im fluss von
hast du ein problem die ja dann komm ran
haftbefehls viert ein krieg pump action
figuren geben auf ist du sohn einer [ __ ]
sich zum kommissar com hk
sonst wirst du c-rohr aber hast es
zurück und effekt da nicht fertig das
ist ein weihnacht ich mache ist strikte
hohen sony gestalt der chor hat den
charts ist jetzt ein foto auf hartplatz
in nizza ist weg jetzt ist es ganz
einfach ich hab grad eben die lyrics aus
dem stand ich habe die parat gehabt
ich habe das lied nicht an gehabt der
sieger ist wieder so nehmen missgeburt
einer der hat noch keinen gefunden ist
ein einziges mal kommt dass jemand
singen können jetzt sucht euch mal die
links raus ja kenne ich
es kommt direkt aus heute zu euch
gefunden
das kannst du damit klar
kennst du diese eine stelle aus ich höre
mir hast du ja das ist kollegen
obdachlose weihnachtsbaum eine [ __ ] und
sie schuldet mir euro beendet
erzählen wenn ich die eine weiß worten
ich muss seine absage macht heute
vergisst niemals altes sprichwort sagt
wer einst lebte kratz der aufmacht
ich lache über seinen gästen würdigkeit
das war ein guter kontrast dessen
beschreibung abonniert in alle und der
der abonniert alle dennis der sache der
bestattungs- und ja es macht ja macht's
gut ja okay leute schreibt mir noch eine
sache in die kommentare wenn ihr bisher
im koffer und zwar schreibt mir wie ich
meine abonnenten zu nennen soll habt ihr
irgendwelche vorschläge
also ich persönlich habe mir gedacht zu
eskalierende oder so scheint einfach
rein wie ich euch nennen soll fasst er
bock drauf habt oder einfach leute und
menschen und abonnenten
wir bekommen falls sich das video
gefallen hat man die wände mehr so klar
wo action wollt dann gebnis seinen
daumen nach oben
die abonniert
du bist echt ihr ein richtiger richtiger
member der generation kanada auf
ich lasse lieber machen
servus